Tucker Carlson pushed a conspiracy
theory on Kerry Lake that was so crazy
that Kerry Lake almost didn't go for it
but she still kind of did there's really
no conspiracy theory too insane for
Kerry Lake remember that Kerry lake is
running for governor in Arizona
she I have my fingers crossed she seems
to be going in the direction of losing
and we'll look at the latest numbers in
a moment Tucker Carlson pushes The
Conspiracy Theory that her opponent
Katie Hobbs
wasn't worried about the election
because Katie Hobbs is running the
election and knew that she was going to
steal it and Carrie Lake recognizes she
can't just come out and say you know
Tucker that's exactly what it is but she
basically says that Tucker isn't wrong
check this out so your opponent is the
Secretary of State
um
she didn't campaign much and she didn't
seem like she needed to campaign a lot
she never debated you and some are
smirking online that well of course she
was always confident uh in her Victory
what's your view of that very common
take on the race
you're trying to get me to say something
that might get me in trouble no no it's
just I've read 50 people say that folks
50 Reddit commenters said it and that's
why Tucker is bringing it up
that that means people are so
distrustful what they're insinuating is
that she knew she could sit back hide in
the basement do nothing that's exactly
what Tucker is saying and when due to
cheating that's what they're insinuating
and I understand why they wouldn't
insinuate that because we've had such
terrible elections they're run poorly
they're ripe with fraud
so your opponent this is you know it
almost seems like Carey lake is going to
hesitate before jumping in on that one
because it could quote get her in
trouble but then actually she does go
for it and he explains he he says what
he's thinking and she says
the entire conspiracy theory unless she
follows it with but I don't believe that
that's true it's very clear that she's
also accepting the very same conspiracy
theory and understand the implication
Tucker Read 50 people said it
so it must be true that's now what the
guy who says you can't trust anything
you read anywhere nobody the media won't
tell you the truth social media is
filled with lies well Tucker read that
50 people wrote this on the internet
could have been Twitter could have been
Reddit who knows and so it must be true
so let's look at the latest numbers
right now right now with 93 percent of
the vote in
Katie Hobbs is leading by one point over
Kerry Lake which is about 26 000 votes
the analyzes I've read are that the
remaining ballots are unlikely to go so
much in Kerry Lake's favor that they
would put her ahead
until it's over
we wait and see make sure you're
following us on Instagram at
davidpackman show and you can follow me
on Instagram at david.pakman quick break
and right back